what have we been seeing over the last
week or so especially in terms of
solidar Batman and the Russian offensive
there yeah a little while ago the
Russians talk solidar and that's given
them some real momentum to move South
about five miles towards back mud which
has always been the main objective of
this part of the battlefield
so what we're going to show you here is
what we've been working on a lot of
these are based on social media posts
the red is Russian controlled what's it
says to be another control yellow is
claimed to be Russian control we've
located some Russian positions along
here these are social media posts where
we've been able to verify them we'll
show you how we do some of the
verification work but we'll show you
with a Ukrainian position first this is
a video posted in the last week or so
um by a Ukrainian Soldier very visible
Landmark there we've seen a lot of that
throughout this war yeah the Ukraine is
very clever when they post these things
on social media they always make sure
they stand in front of a definable
landmark so that it can be geolocated
for authenticity this is how we do it
some of these geolocations are really
tricky take a lot of work some of them
are a lot easier we can do this this is
you know Google Street View which would
be familiar to lots of people
um wherever you are in the world but we
can say this is going into Batman before
the war obviously uh one of those Google
Street View cars coming around if you
take a look around remember that
distinctive building in the background
well
here we are so we can be we can be
confident we can be accurate that this
is posted at that time and this is the
right place and just again to go back to
this map these red dots over here they
represent what we see in a shelling
attacks and we saw reports of a selling
attack at a children's hospital again I
want to show you the street view just to
show you you know
let's have a look at this location let's
see what it looks like again these are
tools accessible to everyone it doesn't
require spy satellites um or on the
ground informants and this is how a lot
of people are doing it so look at that
building very distinctive white and
yellow this is a video posted again
relatively recently and you can see
that's clearly the same hospital this is
on the outskirts of town and we've got
this attack here yes it's difficult to
mistake a building like that
um if it was targeted almost certainly
it was targeted deliberately the crater
is quite interesting it's a very deep
crater let's go back to the Creator
though have a look at that because that
crater is you wouldn't get that with an
artillery shell that sort of crater is
made by a sort of 30 50 kilo Warhead and
that's a missile um so it's a cruise
missile might even be a ballistic
missile but the sort of damage to the
building and the depth of the crater
tells you that that was a pretty big
Armament that hit it so this is where we
are at the moment how important is the
next week what can we expect well I
think this is the end game in Batman now
the Russians have got north and south of
the city at some point they're trying to
close the ring they won't take the
center because the ukrainians hold the
center it's very difficult to attack the
center of a city house by house but if
they get around behind them the
ukrainians will have to decide can we
can we keep the ring from closing or
does do we arrive at the point where
we've got to say okay boys and girls you
know get out we've got to leave now live
to fight another day and I think we're
getting to that point within a few days
well president zielinski has said that
Batman will be a fortress but a very
difficult situation lots of contested
fighting lots of contested information
we will be bringing the latest on Sky
News the latest in verified information
was soon as we get it